you're going to have to consider things
that you've never considered because
what we're doing is we're normalizing
the precursors of
genocide these are the precursors of
genocide make no mistake your your
friendly college students with blue hair
chaning from the river to Sea are
talking about the deaths of millions of
people Eric you get no introduction
because you've been on the Ruben report
1700 times we just check the records
it's an awful lot but it's
been yeah what did I do it's been 84
years um no it's been a it's been a long
time we had to come to London to do this
together we've got 25 minutes we had
dinner last night you're you're I would
say on it when it comes to the state of
the world right now and your concerns
are the things that I think everyone is
concerned about right now I hate to do
that really appreciate it don't know
what to do exactly you know one of the
things that came out of the discussion
last night is that I don't think we are
where we think we are um I give the
analogy that if you have a river that
has always been flowing in one year you
have unseasonably cold temperatures it
freezes over people think they can do
what they've always done they can dive
off the rock into the river and if
they're going to hit ice one year and
they realize that you have to change
your behavior when that there's a phase
change I think that many of the
recourses that we've thought about free
markets free speech um
democracy uh have to be rethought if
they become game and I think one of the
things that we're we're experiencing is
we don't know whether to roll back to a
previous version of ourselves which be
like trying to find safe mode on a
computer where the operating system has
been become corrupted or whether we need
to go forward for things that aren't
capitalism or communism aren't democracy
because in fact there's been a phase
change in our world and I think what
we're doing is avoiding the question of
you know for example if Hamas is is a
democratically elected government and it
engages in pure
terror is democracy what we think it is
um does Free Speech operate the same way
if you have armies of bots that can
confuse people into thinking that uh
there's a mass of people who believe
something which there isn't on day one
but by virtue of the power of persuasion
and social
coercion um people are afraid to hold
simple decent perspectives because every
time they do it they're torn apart by
what seems to be
10,000 accounts telling them that
they're an idiot that they're
cringeworthy that they're over that
they're barbarous and I you know I
watched this happen to you you were one
of the you've seen my Twitter account my
god well that's the the thing right and
I saw the rep the repetition through
what psychologists would call
perseveration where um you know they
would just hit you with the same phrases
over and over again and it causes people
to move away from you because we we have
evolutionary program so I think one of
the things I believe is that um you know
if I think about the early work you and
I did together we were talking about
fake news and what was coming was pretty
prophetic though that that stuff held up
pretty well you're on the short list of
people that uh I would say the
interviews actually do stand up and and
were all park or or let's say
directionally right about where where
this was going to go unfortunately we're
sort of in the prequel version of Star
Wars now and Yoda says oh failed we have
that that seems like in some respects
well and somebody tries to Execute order
66 and so the Jedi uh you know were put
under a lot of pressure but one of the
things that I really appreciate is uh
the number of people who've had their
relationships strained by the Relentless
attack we've all been under uh you know
you used to be a liberal and a lefty I'm
still in that
position um and the fact is is that
we're still talking we're still here man
well and a large number of us uh never
stopped talking to each other somebody
some people have stopped talking to us
but one of the things I I think is
really impressive is the extent to which
we have held together and even if I
disagree with some of the positions
you've now adopted whatever the same
same the same rules go so what I was
going to say is if we want to do the
same thing we were doing all those years
ago we have to figure out what are the
edgy things nobody's prepared to think
that unfortunately are going to be
prophetic and I think one of them is
going to be that you can't simply keep
invoking democracy the free movement of
people diversity is our strength etc etc
because it's going into a place that's
going to be anything but tolerant we're
going to have to learn for example that
we must be intolerant of intolerance to
be tolerant it's like multiplying -1 *
-1 to get a positive number and I think
people are afraid that uh they're going
to have to turn against things that have
always been true but like that winter
where suddenly things are colder than
usual the river stops flowing the way it
always has and you have to watch it so
in the interest of time and we'll pick
this up back when we're in this
anytime you can come to the free state
of Florida but so at dinner last night
we had we had a great table of people
from James Lindsay and Douglas maray and
Melissa Chan and all the PIP GOI and The
Usual Suspects and Coleman Hughes we
this was the whole crew of people trying
to work through all this what we were
whittling it down to last night is
exactly what you just talked about there
the Paradox of Tolerance and what
western societies are going to have to
do in the face of now what I guess you
would call political or cultural
movements that are using our freedoms
against us so in relation to what we saw
here just a day or two before you you
and I arrived in London this uh this
200,000 person siiz protest with Al
Qaeda flags and Hamas flags and River to
the Sea chant and everything else what
does a western Society do related to
speech understanding that Western Europe
has different laws related speech than
we do you're going to have to consider
things that you've never considered
because what we're doing is we're
normalizing the precursors of
genocide these are the pr precursors of
genocide make no mistake your your
friendly college students with blue hair
chaning from the river to the Sea are
talking about the deaths of millions of
people and what's
more the people chanting this are going
to get exactly what they oppose they're
going to get further and further they
are electing the right-wing government
in in Israel that I don't want you may
you may support them but I don't want
that right-wing government in Israel
they want to pull their children from
the rubble because the videos are that
powerful by normalizing the concept of
martyrdom what you're seeing is what
I've called the IDF assisted
suicide um which is how do we get the
IDF to attack our our cities our
population centers you know if we can
just for example put our military
installations proximate to a hospital or
a school uh we can put the IDF in what
I've said is zugang which is a terar f
chess for when and every move your
opponent gives you leaves you worse off
and if isra Israel does not extricate
itself from the dance of death with a
non-traditional foe it's going to find
that its soul will be destroyed and and
I I want to be very clear about this
we're used to the idea of Nations Waring
over things like mineral rights and
shipping lanes and
territory this is not that this is a
non-traditional foe which is saying we
are going to fight you in ways that you
don't want we want you to hurt us as
badly as possible because we're after
your soul as well as the land right and
we're going to do everything imaginable
and unimaginable to you with the process
sure right so we're going to there will
be no rules in terms of what we will do
to you and we will also rip up the rules
in have we will cause your children to
come home from college supportive of
barbarism and atrocities beyond the pale
and it's time to release more video on
mainstream channels to show what people
are supporting how many people have the
guts to watch a uh resistance fighter
take a shovel and attempt to sever the
head of a
corpse uh what is it like to what is it
like to shoot into a porta poot or at
least please show me the uh Brave
resistance fighter shooting directly at
the tire of an ambulance I mean nobody's
getting killed there's nothing graphic
about it but you know what it is it's
like trying to say we want to make sure
that you can't get your your
injured uh to a place where they can be
healed what we're talking about isn't
and mark my words you're talking about a
non-traditional Foe and all of your
intuition is how to fight a traditional
Foe and it's time to recognize that
Western Society has been gained and if
you do not decorr upt and deame what has
happened and you keep saying we want
democracy we want freedom of movement
etc etc on diversity is our strength
you're going to you're you're talking
about
killing many people and by the way this
starts with the Jews and it's not ending
there yeah well that's one of the lines
that I think from from October 9th the
first Monday after this that I
immediately said you think this is about
the Jews you think when you think when
they're done with the Jews there they're
going to go like this but also boy I
want to get this back to the Free Speech
part because the without without getting
too lost in the geopolitics and the
nature of the fight what what do you so
we're here in London there are quite
literally hundreds of thousands if not
more people in this country that
seemingly support this how do you as a
western Nation defend free speech and
defend the right to protest and all that
stuff without self-immolating which
seems like it might be happening maybe
you're a misunderstanding that's what
the people who are the hardest line from
that side have figured out no I know so
they have figured out you are going to
be slow to realize that Free Speech will
kill you well this was the nature of our
conversation last night when it got
pretty hot because because it's the most
difficult conversation and look if you
and I have any basis to relationship as
we get there early before anybody's
willing to talk about these things like
we we would have come across as
conspiracy theorists before the Twitter
files came out before we knew that the
gec or cisa inside of Department of
Homeland Security was actually
coordinating social media what couldn't
couldn't be said what we are going to
have to realize this is that our most
sacred tenants have been weaponized
against us and if we do not put the
brain power into de weaponize it and
realizing that we are in what I've
called the no-name revolution right
years ago 2017 I was saying that on
stage at the Masonic this thing is going
to spread worldwide the the TR the chain
of transmission from the Gaza Strip to
Iran to distracting the US with its what
11 active carrier groups and then China
says how many of those groups have to be
engaged in Regional skirmishes before
the Taiwan straight becomes more
interesting I think what we're not
understanding is the post World War II
era defined a bubble that will never
exist exist again in human history and
that we've spent our entire lives in an
anomalous period thinking that it's
normal so when when a lot of people now
see our kind of geriatric and you know
80 plus year
old that back basically gets to the
thesis of your point right like we've
had a set of leaders and I don't mean it
purely on the age level but but our
intellectual class has been running
around defending something that in some
ways didn't exist anymore whether it was
economically or or related to free
speech or anything else sure so we just
lost Diane Feinstein but the fact is
that our leaders now are basically have
been born in the 40s maybe the late late
30s and a lot of these people they spent
their entire life in the shadow of the
generation that knew the horrors of the
early 20th century and they're not the
adults they're peacetime adults for a
peace time that was only possible
because of the anomalous nature of World
War II and the intellectual power of
atomic Weaponry which caused everyone to
realize how serious life was I can tell
you that because I've been talking about
the need to explode a rare nuclear
device above ground because people have
forgotten Their Fear they thought that
the Cold War uh consigned nuclear
weapons uh to to be an archaic concern
uh nobody is thinking that anymore right
it just it things need to be so concrete
for people to shake them out of their
super that it's almost beyond belief so
is that the bizarre and I hate to use
the term but it's come up a couple times
last is is that the bizarre Silver
Lining to this moment that the barbarity
and the live stream nature of this we
haven't seen it everything no well we've
seen it to a degree we have certainly
not seen it all no no no we haven't seen
it Dave how do you mean I've seen things
and you have seen things on telegram
channels where you have to work really
hard because the Google search engine
seems to hide things from us there is
some desire to normalize things when
there's a Concepts like um strategic
silence where you don't report the news
as a news organization because you're
worried about what the social effect of
it is remember when we did the four
types of fake news on the show years ago
sure said one of the type the most
nefarious type I I quoted you in my book
was the stuff that they won't cover the
stuff that they cover and lie about we
have a little something to work right
but when somebody says you know um the
mass killer uh shouted some a religious
slogan in a foreign language no motive
is
known it's time to end this once and for
all and what we're toing is we're we're
playing with ultimate fire we have to
worry about Russia who in some sense we
may have wronged but they are still
butchers and very very dangerous China
has been playing the long game I have
the ultimate respect for how disciplined
they've been but we have to realize what
they really present India Pakistan
remains incredibly potent Iran and
Israel uh are poised for something and
people have to realize you've never seen
a hydrogen bomb used at anger um the
first time it happens will be like 911
uh raised to the thousandth power
um this was an anomaly and we we
squandered the last bit of this we were
supposed to use the post World War II
piece to figure out how to stabilize
this place M and we failed we talked
about peace dividends we we worried more
about getting swimming pools and and
luxury automobiles is that just the
nature of of human reality you go
through these hard times you build good
things the good people weak and you know
there's fourth turning thing and the
problem is uh I have a different version
of it which is uh Hard Times make strong
men strong men make nuclear weapons in
good times good times make weak men weak
men in nuclear weapons make end times
and people have to stop this fourth
turning nonsense okay so just on the
again we'll do this I'm talking as fast
as I can you you'll come to Miami we'll
do a proper one or we'll do it on Skype
in the meantime but I just want to I'm
really trying to I'm trying to nail down
the the speech component of this so when
you tell me that okay so the river to
the sea is a genocidal chant in Florida
the santis has passed laws you know we
ban some of these uh protests because
he's talking about material and he makes
us uncomfortable by Banning speech
however well it's material support but
yes people are arguing that it's he
Banning spee my point is is that he's
recognized this is where I the phase
transition right so so how do we
encourage that while being respectful of
the ideas and ideals that we care about
how do we make sure that we have the
proper tools which is what he's done to
to export to the rest of the country
maybe the world it has to do with the
fact that you need an interpretation of
the world that allows you not to have a
suicide PCT democracy is not a suicide
pact free speech is not a suicide PCT
tolerance is not a suicide PCT
immigration is not a suicide pack when
you start to realize that someone has
gained your culture there are times when
you have to uninvite a dinner guest
and the fact of the matter is we're
being given a choice and the choice is
do you wish to have a naive relationship
to your ideas and The
Gamers uh come in from outside and
weaponize these things against you or do
you actually realize that you're being
called upon to say what is the sole and
intent of free speech the sole and
intent of democracy and so you're being
given a choice between the letter and
the intent for example if you take the
First Amendment of the Constitution it
says Congress may make no law uh
respecting establish of religion of
prohibiting the free exercise thereof
somebody says well Jihad is part of my
religion I am entitled by the First
Amendment to practice it and I will do
it with your children no you won't and
the reason is is that we have a supreme
court that acts as the oral Torah to the
written Torah that is the Constitution
and so the Supreme Court is going to be
active and it's going to have to figure
out how to get the letter of the
decision law the case law to match the
spirit and intent of the Constitution
it's going to be incredibly unpleasant
but it's a matter of survival and the
Constitution will mean nothing if we
don't survive and we have to realize
that we are now facing existential
threats because of incredible Simplicity
if we have committed one crime during
this period it is we have pushed out the
idea that you can understand Freedom
through simplicities I believe in free
speech I believe in open borders I
believe in democracy I believe in one
man one vote oh really does Wyoming
which has two senators and no people
have the same power in the Senate as
California which has a tremendous number
of people in two senators no there's no
man one man one vote people are going
have to wake up to the idea that they've
been fed childlike aphorisms that do not
actually work for the very difficult
times we're in and what I would say is
let's not wait to become those strong
people uh let's not be weak people let's
realize that we do suspend certain kinds
of Liberty you're not exactly free to
use Free Speech if you're privy to
something about the invasion of beaches
of Normandy uh to just go on social
media and say hey huge troop buildup if
that were happening today we would have
to restrict so the idea is we need to
let people in on how a mature Society
actually handled these things over time
is the easiest way for people that are
maybe not clear about all this to see
how for years guys like us were going to
college campuses and being called Nazis
and had to have security been protested
and microaggressions and all the rest of
it and then the second this thing
happens with Israel suddenly
universities are Defending Your the call
to genocide like to me that's like a
very good example of how we can show
people boy this was only about
controlling you it had nothing well look
but you know there were also issues
where people are confused because Israel
has chosen to do things that are really
uh not comfortable and maybe not right
you know no nation has ever only behaved
ethically Israel's No Ex I don't know
that any Asian nation has behaved more
ethically in this I'm not well but I I
get your metap point there and so my
point is is that there's two basic ways
to do this there's the conservative way
which is you say something simple like
no nation has behaved more ethically
given the difficult situation that
Israel has always been in at an
existential level so that makes good
sense to me then there's the liberal way
of doing it which is that you have a
paragraph that goes on for you know uh
12 pages with lots of footnotes uh and
pointers and references and hyperlinks
it's a slow delay of the beheading you
have to read a lot right like I'm now
I'm not saying this and I'm not saying
that so I'm in the camp that does that
thing right and then the the
conservatives basically say we don't
have time for this here's the simple
thing it's not quite true but it's true
enough it's like it's not true that
there are only two genders but it's true
enough and so you know we're divided I'm
going to talk about no there's
persistent muan duct syndrome and you
have to understand about developmental
identities that divide we've got to
bridge it because even with Five Hour
podcast it starts getting you get the
well you know I I I look to my my my
Muslim brothers and cousins they just
say PB uh they don't say you know in the
name of Allah of the most compassionate
and merciful and Muhammad is only peace
be upon Him PB uh right like let's get
to the chase
right I think we have to stop but we
just started this is very bizarre see
you in Florida there's a lot of people
here if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop screaming
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
no ified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell